hi guys scifi recapped here
before we start warning
spoilers ahead today i'm gonna explain a
2008 japanese action and drama movie
called ichi
this movie follows the story of a blind
young woman who secretly has excellent
sword skills and is involved with a
group of bandits
the movie begins with a blind woman or
goes in japanese named ichi who makes a
living by being a singer
her pretty face attracts a man who once
saw her performance and made her as
mistress
however he attempted to sexually assault
her one night resulting in her defending
herself by cutting his fingers using a
katana sword
sometime later she is talking to her
friend who is also a ghose but she does
not seem to pay attention
she sits by herself on a patio petting a
cat while her friend is having sexual
intercourse with a man
however that man refuses to pay her and
she is beaten by him and his men for
demanding her money the men discover
ichi sitting outside and are allured by
her beauty before they can get their
hands on her a traveling samurai
fujihiro toma appears stopping their
intentions
the men who are bandits do not seem
threatened by his presence in fact they
mock him
attempting to defend himself in ichi
tomah tries to draw his sword but fails
ichi then defeats the men swiftly and
leaves
tomah tries to follow her and offer her
protection by being her bodyguard but
she does not say anything
the deceased men possess a kind of
tattoo on their arms
they arrive at veto in town
a boy kotaro greets ichi and offers to
take her to an inn but she asks to be
guided into a gambling parlor instead
seemingly looking for someone
toma follows her from behind and engages
in a gamble
almost losing all his money to a group
of bandits ichi helps him by whispering
her guesses which turn out to be always
correct winning a lot of money in the
end tomah and ichi leave the parlor only
to be followed by the same group of
bandits
they accuse him of cheating and demand
their money back
ichi notices they have the same tattoos
as her previous attackers
toma again failing to draw his sword
relies on ichi's skill to defend
themselves
she effortlessly kills the bandits which
kotaro finds fascinating then a group of
yakuza who run the inns the shirakawa
clan come by to see the incident the son
of the clan's leader taraji assumes toma
is the one who defeated all the bandits
and asks him to be shirakawa's bodyguard
kotaro wants to correct him but ichi
forbids it
tomah goes with the shirakawa while ichi
continues her journey
kotaro convinces ichi to come to his
house by saying that his father knows
about a blind swordsman someone ichi is
looking for his dad who turns out to be
a drunk person explains that the
government inspector kata okasama will
be in town in three days as part of his
tour and a celebration as planned
that is when ichi may find the person
she is looking for if she stays and
maybe get some money by working as a
performer
meanwhile the bandits called bankito
discover the bodies of their slain
comrades and their leader bonki
identifies the same wounds in all of
them
he deduces that the samurai has a
signature backhand stroke
toma is generously treated and offered
food at the shirakawas they even invite
ichi to perform in front of him and the
others
she begins a mellow song but taraji
quickly dismisses it asking for a more
cheerful tone to lift tomah spirits
however after the performance ichi
refuses to talk to tomah and leaves as
soon as kotaro comes to pick her up
the next day tomah accidentally meets
taraji's father and boss the leader of
the shirakawa kobe
although he is a yakuza he admits to
being afraid of banky and his powers
the rumor says that one cannot look at
him in the face or they will get
defeated due to his severely burned face
being so menacing the shirakawa are
counting on tomah to defeat bonkey
because his bandits have long disturbed
the piece of the in town and driven
visitors away
in the afternoon toma meets ichi and
kotaro who are fishing by the lake
he curiously asks her why she would not
want to be involved with anything or
anyone to which she replies that blind
people like her do not understand
boundaries and cannot clearly
distinguish between bad and good people
she also actually does not like kids but
they are more trustworthy than adults
she almost abruptly leaves but then
tomah asks her to fight him using a
wooden stick
she accepts it and turns out toma is a
much better swordsman than she is
however he is always traumatized to draw
his katana due to him accidentally
hurting his mother when he trained as a
little boy causing her to go blind
back in town the people are busy
preparing for the inspector's arrival
the inspector arrives and is immediately
escorted to watch a kabuki performance
however the bankito bandits have also
arrived and started a riot during the
celebration to draw the man who had
slain their members
they drive the inspector away and aim to
kill the shirakawa taraji tries hard to
protect his father while tomah struggles
to help but is still unable to draw his
sword
unfortunately kobe is killed and toma is
knocked unconscious
they are unsure that toma is the man
they are looking for but decide to bring
him anyway
however ichi stops them and claims that
she is the one having slain the bandits
she proves herself by slaying some of
the banquito men before they agree to
take her to meet bonki
brought before him ichi is once again
asked to prove that she is the great
swordsman banky is looking for
after defeating two more bankito banki
finally stands up and draws his katana
he says that he once knew a man having
the same backhand stroke as her but he
passed away from a disease
that man zotto ichi a great blind
swordsman is who ichi is looking for
he then defeats her easily leaving her
fatally wounded meanwhile toma is beaten
by the surviving shirakawa clan due to
being unable to protect him in the
previous assault but taraji disapproves
of them saying they need all the help
they can get to defeat the banqueto
meanwhile ichi is left to die on a pile
of rotten corpses but banky secretly
walks to her and whispers that if she
lives he will take care of her she
slightly moves her hand after he left
reaching for a small bell given by
zaduichi when she was little however it
slips out of her hand and is lost she
flashbacks to her childhood turns out
she was blind from birth and spent most
of her time with zadoichi doing chores
and secretly training with swords and
sticks
because he traveled a lot she was left
in the care of a group of ghos who
taught her to sing and play instruments
one day the ghost performed and one man
was particularly fascinated by ichi's
beauty causing him to assault her she
was expelled from the group and later
she defended herself from the man who
assaulted her too
since then she wanders to find zadawichi
again who she believes as her father
then meets toma along the way
meanwhile tomah attempts to save ichi
with the help of kotaro's father they
set ablaze their path so the bankito
could not follow them bonkey asks for
ichi back but tomah after proclaiming
his name refuses to do so and leaves
vanki swears revenge
finally waking up ichi quickly sits up
although she is still badly hurt and
cries about how she desperately wants to
see zotto ichi one last time as that is
the only thing avoiding her to end her
own life because she does not have
reasons to live anymore
hearing that tomah consoles her
convincing her that she should live
she rests again allowing tomah to slip
out and help the shirakawa fight the
bankito
taraji and his men are preparing to
fight the banqueto
he tells tomah not to run away again
this time
he is aware that the bankito far
outnumber them by two to one however he
encourages his men to at least kill two
bandits before they are defeated
bonkey and his men finally arrive and a
battle ensues
both sides suffer heavy losses however
tomah still fails to draw his sword
despite the horror he witnesses
meanwhile ichi wakes up and discovers
that tomah has gone missing kotaro tells
him about the fight in town and she
quickly leaves to help
bonkey exclaims that tomah steps forward
and gives ichi to him
taraji almost takes his place as he
seems nowhere to be found but then he
appears and is finally able to overcome
his fear and draw his katana they engage
in a sword fight ending with both
fatally wounded ichi appears and quickly
comes over to tomah seeing him die in
her arms after saying that she must not
lose hope
vonkey manages to get up in attempts to
attack her but now she is prepared and
successfully defeats him the remaining
surviving bankito flee for their lives
and peace is restored in veto in town
sometime later taraji assumes the clan
leader position after his late father
and rebuilds the town
ichi and kotaro visit thomas grave where
ichi plays his favorite song the slow
melody she performed once at the
sharakoa residence
she intends to go to toma's clan to
place his sword on his mother's grave so
she bids farewell to kotaro
before leaving she gives him the same
small bell zotta which he once gave her
for a keepsake kotaro asks whether he
will see her again to which she only
replies with a smile
subscribe to watch more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out thank you for
watching